herzlich willkommen hier zur heutigen
Pressekonferenz her wahlnachlese der
Landtagswahlen in Bayern und in
Hessen ja um es in der
infantilisierten Sprache des
Bundeskanzlers zu formulieren ist das
Ergebnis in Hessen und Bayern ein
doppelwums gewesen wir haben
Rekordergebnisse eingefahren und an
dieser Stelle möchte ich mich ganz
herzlich
bedanken bei den vielen ehrenamtlichen
Wahl käfen in den beiden Bundesländern
und vor allen Dingen möchte ich mich
ganz herzlich bei den
Spitzenkandidaten bedanken die hier
oben heute sitzen es ist mir eine ganz
ganz große Ehre dass ihr heute hier seid
lieber Martin lieber Katrin lieber
Robert ihr habt wirklich einen ganz
hervorragenden Job gemacht die ganze
Partei ist natürlich sehr sehr stolz auf
die Leistung und dieses Dankeschön
möchte ich gerne auch im Namen von Tino
kopaller Ausrichten der eben heute
leider nicht hier sein kann aufgrund der
Ereignisse in der letzten Woche er nutzt
den heutigen Tag noch zum Besuch
von Ärzten also er muss Arzttermine
wahrnehmen und wird dann morgen wieder
im Bundestag in der Fraktionssitzung
sein so Rekordergebnisse für die AFD äh
in Hessen ganz klar zweitstärkste Kraft
das ist ein ganz klares Wählervotum in
Deutschland sehen wir einen
wederschwenk ganz klar von links nach
rechts es ist ein Votum gegen die
ubquitäre Verbotspolitik die betrieben
wird nicht nur auf der Bundesebene aber
auch auf den landesebenen die Leute
wollen diese Verbotspolitik nicht sie
wollen nicht eine Politik gegen die
eigenen Interessen
weitertragen und das ist das
Ergebnis bei den Landtagswahlen
ähm einhergehend hat die AFD einen
Rekordzuwachs an Mitgliedern wir haben
die 35 000 Grenze durchschritten und
eben in Hessen sind wir erstmalig in
einem westlichen Parlament zweitstärkste
Kraft geworden und da noch mal vielen
herzlichen Dank es ist ein deutliches
demokratisches Votum der Wähler an die
AFD und der Wähler will die politische
Wende weitere Ausgrenzung und
Diskriminierung der Alternative für
Deutschland wäre eine undemokratische
wählerverachtung Stichwort Brandmauer es
ist ein ganz klares Votum für eine
mitittte
Rechtsregierung und diese
brandmauerdiskussion das habe ich auch
schon mehrfach gesagt ist zutiefst
undemokratisch weil Millionen von
Wählern ausgeschlossen werden aus dem
Korridor und ähm ich sage Ihnen v raus
dass eine Verachtung und Missachtung der
Alternative für Deutschland eine
Ausgrenzung von
Regierungsverantwortung nicht auf Dauer
durchhaltbar sein wird und das Ergebnis
zeigt auch deutlich die AFD ist kein
ostphänomen mehr sondern eine
gesamtdeutsche Volkspartei geworden wir
sind also angekommen wir werden nicht
mehr nur als reine Protestpartei
wahrgenommen sondern uns werden in
weitesten Feldern Problemlösung
Kompetenzen zugeschrieben und als
stärkste Oppositionskraft jetzt in
Hessen und Bayern steht uns auch endlich
mal der
vizepräsidentenposten zu der uns seit
Jahren verweigert wird nicht nur in den
Landesparlamenten aber auch auf
Bundesebene auch dies ist ein zutiefst
undemokratischer Akt den wir seit Jahren
über uns ergehen lassen
müssen vielleicht noch abschließ end ein
paar Worte zu der Wählerwanderung die
AFD hat aus allen Lagern gewonnen im
übrigen die einzige Partei die nicht
verloren hat sondern aus allen Lagern
Zuwächse errungen hat das ist ein ganz
klares Signal dass wir uns auch in der
Breite auch in allen Wählerschichten
etablieren und vor allen
Dingen die starken Zuwächse bei den
Altersgruppen die im Erwerbsleben stehen
wir sind die Partei der arbeitenden
Bevölkerung der Familien die eben von
dieser Verbotspolitik betroffen sind von
den Landesregierungen als auch von der
Bundesregierung und vor allen Dingen
haben wir enorme
erstfehlerzuwächse erhalten bei diesen
Landtagswahlen ich möchte es jetzt
einfach mal dabei belassen und das Wort
sehr gerne an unsere Spitzenkandidaten
übergeben und bedanke mich herzlich für
die
Aufmerksamkeit ja meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren auch von mir ein
herzliches Willkommen hier zu diese
Pressekonferenz die AFD ist ja stärkste
Kraft in den neuen Bundesländern deshalb
haben uns ja einige Vertreter anderer
Parteien immer als ostdeutsches Phänomen
bezeichnet sie wurden gestern eines
Besseren belehrt denn mit dem gestrigen
Wahl Wahlabend hat auch in den alten
Bundesländern eine neue politische
Zeitrechnung begonnen die AFD ist die
Partei der direkten Demokratie der
Vernunft und des
Verantwortungsbewusstseins in Bayern
sind wir mit
14,6% Oppositionsführer worden wir haben
4,4% Punkte zugelegt das ist ein
historisches Ergebnis für unsere Bayern
AFD das bedeutet wir sind jetzt in der
Mitte der Gesellschaft angekommen und
genau dort werden wir auch bleiben das
sieht man schon allein an der
Wählerwanderung als einzige Partei
konnte unsere bayerische AFD allen
anderen Parteien Wählern Stimmen
wegnehmen mindestens 80.000 von der CSU
40.000 von der FDP 30.000 von den Freien
wern 20.000 von der SP SPD und sogar
20.000 von den
Grünen die ampelparteien haben gestern
in Bayern ein Fiasko erlebt besonders
die FDP die sich ja gerne als Partei der
bürgerlichen Freiheit verkauft aber als
Mehrheitsbeschaffer in der Koalition
jede ideologische begründete
Fehlentscheidung von rotgrün mitgetragen
hat sind sie gestern zurecht unter die
Räder gekommen wer die Wäller in so
einer Weise täuscht und sich um sich nur
postnummern zu sichern hat es meiner
Meinung nach auch nicht besser verdient
und nicht anders verdient die Ampel ist
tot angesichts der mehrheitsverhältn in
unserem Lande würden uns Neuwahlen gut
tun die AFD ist die Partei der direken
Demokratie und die mit Abstand
demokratischste Partei in Deutschland
wir fordern unter anderem
Volksentscheide auf Bundesebene
Direktwahl des Bundespräsidenten
abszeitbegrenzung für Kanzler und
Minister und immer mehr Wähler erkennen
dies und Politiker anderer Parteien und
viele
Medienvertreter sie glauben ihnen nicht
mehr
ähm die WählerInnen Wähler glauben den
den anderen Parteien nicht mehr dass wir
undemokratisch sein und deswegen haben
wir deutlich an Rückhalt und Vertrauen
gewonnen die Hetze von Steinmeier Süder
und
Konsorten hat nichts bewirkt und sie ist
nicht aufgegangen besonders bei jenen
Bürger die sich zuvor frustriert und
enttäuscht von der Demokratie abgewandt
haben von ihnen den Nichtwählern konnten
wir 70.000 aktivieren und in die
demokratische Teilhabe zurückholen wir
sind also die Demokratie für lebendige
in unserem Land eines zeigen die
gestrigen Landtagswahlen in Bayern auch
dass die sogenannten sozialen Parteien
ihre eigentlichen Wähler im Stich
gelassen haben vermutlich weil sie sich
lieber mit gendertoiletten oder
binnensternchen beschäftigen oder
schwere Waffen in Kriegsgebiete schicken
die AFD ist die Partei der
wirtschaftlichen Freiheit und des
schlankenstaates aber in Bayern sind wir
auch die Partei der fleißigen Arbeiter
unter ihnen wurden wir gestern mit
31% stärkste Kraft das starke Ergebnis
unserer bayerischen AFD ist ein Zeichen
dafür dass sich die Menschen einen
Politikwechsel wünschen hin zu einer
Politik für die eigenen
Leute ich danke allen Bürgern die bei
dieser W Vertrauen in uns gesetzt haben
von ganzen Herzen wir werden alles dafür
tun sie nicht zu enttäuschen weiter
schonungslos die Wahrheit ans Licht zu
bringen und ihnen eine bessere
Alternative zur Politik der allparteien
zu bieten denn die nächsten Jahre werden
Schicksalsjahre für Bayern Deutschland
und unsere Demokratie sein schon allein
das gescheiterte Attentat auf Tino
kupalla und die mordren gegen unsere
Bundesvorsitzende dr Alis Weidel und
ihre Familie
zeigen wie dringend die demokratische
und freiheitliche Position in diesem
Lande benötigt wird aber vor allem wie
Recht wir mit unserer Politik haben wir
als bayerische AFD werden künftig noch
konsequenter aufzeigen dass die CSU den
katastrophalen Weg der ampelparteien
mitgeht die Abschaffung der sicheren
energiegrundlagen unseres Landes der
illegale
massenzustrum die gescheiterte
wirtschaftsfanz und Außenpolitik von der
Sozialpolitik mal ganz zu schweigen das
alles ist die Politik der CSU und ihrer
Mehrheitsbeschaffer den Freien Wählern
wir werden in den nächsten 5 Jahren eine
angriffslustige aber vor allem weiterhin
eine sachliche und faktenbasierte
Oppositionspolitik machen und ich
verspreche auch wir werden weiter den
Finger in die Wunde legen darauf freue
ich mich sehr ich danke auch meinem
kspitzenkandidaten montin Böhm und all
unseren Kandidaten und Wahlkämpfen und
ganz besonders unser Basis sie sind das
Fundament auf dem unser Erfolg gebaut
ist der doppelwums in Bayern und Hessen
war erst der Anfang ich freue mich auf
die Wahlen im Osten im nächst J da geht
erst so richtig los vielen
Dank ja mehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Katrin herzlichen Dank für deine sehr
präzisen Ausführungen zu dem gestrigen
Wahlabend die ich nur an drei Stellen
noch ergänzen und dementsprechend auch
erweitern mag zum einen unsere
oppositionsführerschaft die wir in
Bayern errungen haben 0,2% Vorsprung auf
dem Papier nicht viel aber in den
parlamentarischenen liegt wel dazwischen
wir haben das erste Rederecht nach
Ministerpräsidenten wir haben das erste
Rederecht nach den Fachministern und die
Zeit wird zeigen ob sich die
kartellparteien in München weiter truen
uns den Posten des
vizeministerpräsidenten und den Posten
eines Mitglieds in der parlamentarischen
Kontrollkommission zu verwehren ob Söder
ob eiwange sich das leisten können so
undemokratisch der wirklich wahen
demokratischen Opposition im 19
Bayerischen Landtag sich zu widersetzen
der zweite Punkt den ich rausgreifen mag
das ist die kauser eiwanger selber
eiwanger als quasi
Mehrheitsbeschaffer von Söder der in
absehbarer Zeit in einem großen
Spannungsbogen in Bayern stehen wird wir
haben in ungefähr 23 Monaten eine
Bundestagswahl vor der Brust dort wird
alleer Voraussicht nach eiwanger als
Spitzenkandidat der Freien Wähler auf
Bundesebene antreten und er wird damit
Gegnerschaft zu Söder darstellen
innerhalb von Bayern und diesen
Spannungsbogen zu überstehen auch
innerhalb einer dann bestehenden
Regierungskoalition zwischen CSU und
Freien Wählern des wird eine der großen
rausforderungen vor den wir als
Opposition die das dann dementsprechend
anklagt und die Defizite beschreiben
kann das wird eine der Defizite die wir
rausarbeiten können und die aber auch
unserem bayerischen freist ST für viele
viele Monate im Bundestagswahlkampf
schwer belasten wird und mit diesem Wort
Bundestagswahlkampf will ich beide in
die Zukunft schauen und wir müssen
verstehen die Wahlen die wir jetzt
gewonnen haben für uns für unsere blaue
Farbe in Hessen und in Bayern und die im
kommenden Jahr bei den drei
mitteldeutschen Wahlen und kurz davor
bei der Europawahl ihre gute Fortsetzung
finden werden des sind Perspektiven für
die Bundestagswahl für die nächste und
das wird der tags an dem diese
ampelabrisstruppe die nichts anderes zu
tun hat wie unsere Heimat zu
deindustrialisieren das wird der Tag
sein an dem die Messe gelesen wird und
die Stärke die wir in Bayern Zeichen die
Stärke die die Freunde in Hessen Zeichen
und selbstverständlich auch unsere
Freunde in Mitteldeutschland bei den
nächsten drei Landtagswahlen die wird
entscheidend dafür sein dass auch in
Berlin wieder Vernunft einzieht und dass
wir eine vernünftige Regierung rechts
der Mitte für unsere Bundesrepublik
bekommt das ist die Perspektive mit der
ich enden mag herzlichen
Dank
ja einen schönen guten Tag in die Runde
ähm das Ergebnis in Hessen
18,4% das ist
atemberaubend ist nicht nur ataubend ist
auch schlafraubend also ich habe keine
Minute
geschlafen aber es ist ein schönes
Gefühl
die AFD wurde in Hessen gegründet vor
über 10 Jahren in Oberursel und jetzt
haben wir es gestern geschafft das mit
Abstand beste Ergebnis der AFD in
Westdeutschland jemals zu erzielen und
wäre diese Stigmatisierung und defierung
nicht wäre es völlig normal dass die
beiden Wahlsieger nämlich die CDU und
die AFD
koalitionsgespräch miteinander führen
wir bilden mit unserem Wahlprogramm in
Hessen bei vielen Themen z.B Begrenzung
der Masseneinwanderung Senkung der
Grunderwerbssteuer wiederinstieg in die
Kernkraft den Willen der Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung ab und ich frage mich wie
lange kann man eigentlich in einer
Demokratie Politik gegen den Willen der
der Mehrheit der Bevölkerung machen und
darauf reagieren ja auch die Menschen
und deswegen haben sie aus meiner Sicht
auch sehr stark in Hessen die AFD
gewählt meines Wissens nach sind wir in
einem westdeutschen Landesparlament als
zum allerersten Mal zweit stärkste Kraft
geworden und
auch hier stellt sich in der Tat die
Frage ob
die fortgesetzte Praxis der letzten 5
Jahre in Hessen dass wir keinen
Vizepräsident stellen dürfen ob das
aufrecht zuerhalten ist was ich
bemerkenswert finde ist es haben viele
Bürger zum allerersten Mal die AFD
gewählt und das ist aus meiner Sicht ein
enormer
Vertrauensvorschuss den wir auch die
nächsten Jahre erfüllen wollen mit
absolut seriöser bürgerlich
konservativer freiheitlicher Politik ähm
ich habe hier auch eine Statistik von
Infratest dimap die mich sehr freut
nämlich eine Analyse der Erstwähler bei
der Landtagswahl in Hessen dort hat die
CDU mit 22% am besten abgeschnitten aber
dann kommt schon auf Platz 2 die AFD mit
15% ich möchte das deswegen erwähnen
weil es immer heißt dass wir zwei
Ostdeutschland bei den Erstwählern stark
abschneiden aber in Westdeutschland
nicht sie sehen an diesem Beispiel dass
sich in Westdeutschland einiges
verändert hat
wir sind überdurchslülich stark bei ähm
den Menschen ähm die zwischen 25 und 2 9
Jahren alt sind die Menschen die im
Arbeitsleben stehen die auch diesen stat
zu einem großen Teil finanzieren wir
wissen alle dass die Belastungen für die
Bürger immer höher werden äh ob es jetzt
bedingt ist durch die hohe Inflation die
Lebensmittelpreise hohe Energiekosten
und die sehen dass eine Ampel
Bundesregierung darauf keine Rücksicht
nimmt und immer neue losten plant in
Hessen haben wir bei dem wichtigsten
Thema denke ich für die Menschen die die
AFD wählen nämlich die
Masseneinwanderung die Situation dass
der Ministerpräsident Boris rin seit ein
paar Monaten ähm im Grunde genommen die
Argumentation der AFD übernommen hat und
für eine Begrenzung der
Masseneinwanderung plediert gleichzeitig
aber sich ein freiwilliges
Aufnahmeprogramm für Afghanen leistet
und das ist von der Symbolik schlicht
und ergreifend unglaubwürdig und ich
habe immer gesagt in diesem Wahlkampf
ähm nur eine starke AFD übt Druck aus
und deswegen ist eine Stimme für die AFD
eine Stimme die wirkt man kann dieser
hässischen CDU nicht trauen dass sie
nach der Wahl wirklich eine Kurswende
hinlegt bei dem Thema Masseneinwanderung
und ich denke dass viele Bürger diese
Argumentation gefolgt
sind ja vielen Dank wir treten dann in
die Fragerunde
ein warten Sie bitte bis sie ein
Mikrofon haben und nennen Sie uns dann
ihren Namen und für wen Sie heute hier
sind und sagen Sie uns bitte auch an wen
sich Ihre Frage richtet dann bitte ich
Sie um die ersten
Handzeichen ja hallo Dominik gugemos
neue Berliner redaktionsgesellschaft
meine Frage geht an Frau Weidel
ich würde gerne nach vorne schauen sie
haben morgen fraktionsvorstandswahl
sie haben schon oder Sie wollen
Kanzlerkandidatin werden wä es nicht
auch an der Zeit dass jetzt alleine die
Fraktionsspitze
übernehmen also die Doppelspitze
innerhalb der Bundestagsfraktion als
auch in der Bundesspitze der Partei hat
sich bewährt
Tino kropaler und ich wir haben ein sehr
gutes Verhältnis ein sehr
vertrauensvolles Verhältnis und wir
ergänzen uns auch sehr gut in dieser
Legislatur möchten wir gerne genauso
weitermachen wir werden als
Doppelspitze morgen kandidieren und wir
ergänzen uns auch in dieser Funktion
sehr gut also ich freue mich auf die
weitere Zusammenarbeit auf die weiteren
zwei Jahre
in dieser Legislatur zusammen mit Tino
kropaller und zu der Kanzlerkandidatur
ich habe es auch gestern schon ähm Frau
Schausten äh dort auch erklärt in der
Sendung das ganze ist noch gar nicht
ausgemacht es ist natürlich völlig klar
dass wenn wir uns strukturell als
weitstärkste Kraft weit vor der
Kanzlerpartei SPD etablieren und auch
manifestieren dass wir ein
Führungsanspruch
stellen wir bewegen uns dort aber auch
ganz klar in einem Spannungsfeld mit der
Perspektive einer Regierungsbeteiligung
im Jahre
2025 und wir sehen diese Perspektive
natürlich deutlich klarer am Ende des
nächsten Jahres nach den ostdeutschen
Landtagswahlen nicht wahr weil dort
sehen wir ob die
Brandmauer nicht sehr schnell zerbröselt
und die Alternative für Deutschland in
Regierungsverantwortung erstmalig in
einem ostdeutschen Landtag kommt dann
ist es auch so dass wir viele Bewerber
haben viele viele
Parteikollegen die sich vorstellen
können ebenso
so eine Funktion eines Kanzlers oder
Kanzlerkandidaten auszufüllen und das
besprechen wir dann eben nächstes Jahr
intern wenn es an der Zeit ist und
vielleicht noch ein letztes und das ist
uns als Alternative für Deutschland
immanent wichtig bei uns entscheiden das
die Mitglieder wir sind keine
funktionärsgetriebene Partei wie alle
anderen Parteien sondern bei uns
entscheidet das die Basis entweder auf
einem Bundesparteitag oder in einer
Mitgliederbefragung so wie wir das ja
eben im Jahre 2021 ebenfalls gemacht
haben weil uns das sehr sehr wichtig ist
und wir fen ab von der
Hinterzimmerpolitik sind und
dementsprechend dass nächstes Jahr wenn
es dann eben an der Zeit ist die
Mitglieder auch entscheiden
können dann bitte ich um die nächste
Frage einmal torbenlehing
mitteldeutscher Rundfunk eine Frage an
Sie Frau Weidel sie haben gerade eben
gesagt dass es zutiefst antidemokratisch
sei wenn die CDU jetzt nicht in erwegung
ziehen würde auch in Hessen mit der AFD
zu koaliieren ist nicht gerade diese
Sichtweise sehr antidemokratisch Frage
an Sie Frage an Frau Ebner Steiner sie
hatten gerade von ein Zitat Attentat auf
Herrn kropalla berichtet können Sie da
noch mal erläutern wie sie zu dieser
Erkenntnis
kommen mir geht es um das grundsätzliche
so wie vielen anderen Millionen von
Menschen auch die Brandmauer ist deshalb
undemokratisch weil es per se Millionen
von Wählerstimmen ausschließt aus
einem
demokratischen
pluralistischen
Konsens und das ist etwas was ich noch
mal wiederholen möchte was was ich alsz
ti
undemokratisch betrachte sie können
nicht einfach stimmen die Sie per se als
missliebig irgendwie deklarieren wollen
aus irgendwelchen unsinnigen ideologisch
ideologischen Gründen ausschließen das
geht nicht das ist doch eine Demokratie
nicht angemessen wir sind doch als
Volksvertreter gewählt worden um auch
andere Meinung anzuhören das gehört mit
zu unserer Arbeit das gehört mit zu
unserem Job wir gehen doch auch nicht
dahin und schließen per se andere
Meinung aus sondern eine Demokratie eine
lebendige Demokratie lebt doch davon von
einem vielfältigen lebhaften
Meinungsaustausch und möglicherweise
auch sein eigenes Meinungsbild
korrigieren zu können sollte man
falschliegen und Pere zu sagen nein mit
denen und mit denen rede ich nicht die
Meinung gefällt mir nicht das halte ich
für völlig falsch und das halte ich auch
ehrlich gesagt für für übergriffig dass
Menschen die eine bestimmte Meinung
haben permanent in eine Ecke
reingestellt werden nein mit denen reden
wir nicht und sie sehen natürlich auch
dass wir uns hier in einem
gesellschaftspolitischen Spannungsfeld
bewegen
wo sie dann eben auch Stimmung aufladen
können indem sie Menschen ausgrenzen
auch das ist falsch das sehen wir ja
auch und ich glaube dass wir insgesamt
deutlich unaufgeregte argumentieren
müssen und sachlich über die Argumente
austauschen das hätte ich mir schon bei
der Corona maßnahmenpitik gewünscht da
hat man ja auch eben die Corona maßnahm
Gegner mit kovidioten und irgendwelchen
Sektierern gleichgesetzt und im
Nachhinein sieht man eigentlich dass man
die Menschen und auch die Ärzte die das
auch mit kritisiert haben hätte anhören
müssen und auch hier muss ich ihn ganz
ehrlich sagen da hätte ich mir auch
deutlich mehr
Grundlagenarbeit von den Medien
gewünscht hier auch deutlich
transparenter aufzuklären und nicht nur
die regierungsmeinung
abzubilden glaub die zweite Frage genau
genau also in Ingolstadt ist die sart
von Söder Steinmeier und den linken
Medien aufgegangen es gab dort auch eine
Gegenkundgebung vom DGB und von allen
sogenannten demokratischen Parteien von
CSU Freie Wähler über SPD zu den Grünen
Tino kopaller hat sich dort eine
Nadelstich ver letetzung durch
Fremdeinwirkung zugezogen und es ist
selbstverständlich ein Attentat auf
unseren Bundessprecher weil der
Bundessprecher stieg aus dem Auto aus er
hat mich freundlich begrüßt er war
kraftvoll und ein paar Minuten später
ist er dann zusammengesagt was soll das
anderes sein als ein feiges Attentat auf
unsem
Bundessprecher dann bitte zur nächsten
Frage Sternberg guten Tag eine Frage an
Frau Weide jetzt haben wir über die
Vorfall von Paller gesprochen ich w gern
von Ihnen erfahren wie denn die
Sicherheitslage wenn sie es sagen können
gegenüber Ihnen und Ihrer Familie zur
Zeit ist und es gibt da von da ja auch
die m fraktionsvorstandswahen schon
erwähnt worden von fraktionsfze
Kleinwächter ein Brief der kursiert von
heute morgen indem er ihnen schwere
Vorwürfe macht dass sie äh die
Veranstalter mötler reut falsch
informiert hätten dass sie äh diejenigen
die dort von einem also waril in der
offiziellen Absage von einer
andauernden Bedrohungslage die Rede war
und diejenigen die dort eben von einem
safehaus gesprochen haben hiner Zitat im
Stich gelassen Zitat Ende hätten
wie sehen Sie das dann noch eine Frage
an Herrn
lambre ich habe mir die Ergebnisse in
den hochbogen der AFD in Hessen in Nord
und Osthessen mal detailliert angeguckt
und was mir dann auffiel war äh dass
äh teilweise die besten Ergebnisse in
Orten haben wo es überhaupt keine
kommunale Verankerung
gibt wie sieht das aus mit der
kommunalen Verankerung in der AFD auch
im Westen und viicht noch wieder eine
Frage zurück an Frau Weidel in dem
Zusammenhang es gab gestern auch noch
eine obwahl in Bitterfeld Wolfen das war
jetzt die zweite obwahl wo die AFD im
Vorfeld sagte das geht sicher für uns
aus
wieder einmal hat es nicht geklappt
wann kommt denn nun dieser von ihnen
angekündigte kommunale Durchmarsch im
Osten viele Fragen Herr Sternberg ich
möchte sie der Reihenfolge nach
beantworten zunächst
zu meiner Sicherheitslage werde ich mich
aus polizeitaktischen Gründen darum
hatte mich auch die Polizei gebeten
nicht äußern
äh fakt ist und das ist ja auch Presse
öffentlich gewesen dass eine
Antiterroreinheit in meinem Fall und im
Fall der Familie zum Einsatz kam die uns
aus unserer Wohnung evakuiert hat und an
einen sicheren Ort brachte ein
unbekannten Ort und wir mitten in einem
Ermittlungsverfahren sind warum ich mich
dazu nicht Weier weiter äußern darf ich
muss auch zugeben dass
ähm dass dieser Vorfall
mit
M dem
dahinterliegenden vermuteten
Tatbeständen
bei mir einen bleibenden Eindruck
hinterlassen hat über die
deterorierende
Sicherheitslage und
ich das sehr ernst nehme
ähm bezüglich dieser einen Veranstaltung
in mötlerreut ist dazu zu sagen dass
ich nach dem
ich mit meiner gesamten Familie
evakuiert wurde
m zurück nach Berlin bin um meine
Pflichten als Abgeordnete und als
Fraktionsvorsitzende nachzukommen und
ich habe in der Woche vor der
Veranstaltung in mötlerreut
dem
Veranstalter persönlich in meinem Büro
abgesagt habe ihm die Gründe dargelegt
genauso wie ich das gerade ihn gegenüber
getan habe das eingeordnet es gab eine
ganz klare Sprachregelung zu diesem
Vorfall
ähm und
ähm an diese Sprachregelung wurde sich
von dem Veranstalter in mötlerreut nicht
gehalten darum Weise ich
die ja soweit Alis weitel zu dem was sie
schon erklärt hat
in Bezug auf die Anschlagsdrohungen
gegen ihre Familie das ist bekannt neu
die Interpretation der bayerischen
Spitzenkandidatin Katrin Ebner Steiner
Bezug auf das was Tino grupaller
Ingolstadt wieder fahren sein soll sie
spricht von einem Attentat und auf
Nachfrage hat sie auch noch erklärt wen
sie mittelbar für dieses Attentat noch
mit verantwortlich sieht dies sogenannte
Attentat ein interessanter Aspekt den
wir bisher noch nicht gehört haben ja im
Verlaufe der
Pressekonferenz hat auch der
Spitzenkandidat der häsischen AFD Robert
lambru quasi ein indirektes
koalitionsangebot an Boris rin abgegeben
auch die AFD in Hessen stünde jetzt
bereit zur Regierungsbeteiligung er hat
einen gewissen Anspruch angemeldet wie
Alice Weidel auch gerade dass man so
viele Wählerstimmen bei der
Regierungsbildung nicht außen vorlassen
kann es gibt allerdings auch Parteien
die noch stärker sind wie die Union z.B
im Bundestag die auch in der Opposition
sein muss weil sie keine Mehrheit
gefunden hat interessant im Zusammenhang
mit der Wahl gestern den Wahlen in
Bayern und in Hessen ist eine Umfrage
unter AFD Wählern und da gibt es einen
signifikanten Unterschied zwischen
beiden Bundesländern in Bayern sind etwa
gleich viele afdwähler entweder
überzeugungswähler oder Protestwähler
werden in Hessen die Zahl der
Protestwähler die überzeugungswähler
immer noch überwiegt das heißt also
möglicherweise verfestigt sich jetzt
hier auch ein Bild verfestigt auch ein
wählerstamm für die AFD für die und das
ist ja schon jetzt häufiger auch auf
dieser Pressekonferenz gesagt worden
offensichtlich es kein großes Problem
mehr ist in der Öffentlichkeit auch sich
zur AFD zu bekennen also es ist keine
reine Protestpartei mehr inwiew weit man
die Protestwähler die es in der Partei
natürlich auch noch gibt und für diese
Partei noch zurückgewinnen kann ist eine
ganz andere Frage aber eine ganz
drängende Frage ich glaube dass die
Parteien der demokratischen mit
wie sie sich nennen also die
ampelparteien und die Union nicht mehr
viel Zeit haben sich äh diese Wähler
Rinnen und Wähler von der AFD
zurückzuholen das zeigt diese Umfrage
glaube ich auch ganz deutlich die AFD
ist einem Aufwind in einem für sich
gesehen sehr guten Zustand sie fühlt
sich gestärkt durch diese Wahlen was
denn sonst nächstes Jahr ist die Wahl
zum Europäischen Parlament das wäre die
erste Wahl 2014 dem AFD Kandidaten in
ein Parlament eingezogen sind da
verspricht man sich auch viel unter
anderen wegen der Migrationspolitik ja
ein europäisches Problem und es sind
drei Wahlen in Ostdeutschland alle samt
Hochburgen der AFD wo sie im Moment nach
Umfragen stärkste Partei sind und das
erklärt auch das selbstbewusst sein dass
hier auch die Parteiführung vor allen
Dingen Alis Weidel zur Schau gestellt
haben soweit aus Berlin aus der
Bundespressekonferenz wo diese
Pressekonferenz der AFD stattfand zurück
zuur Claudia Davis nach Bonn